OWN PEOPLE FIRST.
>> CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
HILLARY CLINTON RECENTLY
CONDEMNED THE POLICIES WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT AS HORRIFIC WHICH
IS STILL SURELY COMING AS NEWS.
IN 2003 THIS IS WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON SAID ABOUT THE
CRISIS ON THE BORDER.
WATCH THIS.
>> I AM ADAMANTLY AGAINST
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND PEOPLE
HAVE TO STOP EMPLOYING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
>> NOTHING HAS CHANGED SINCE
THEN OF COURSE EXCEPT FOR HER
PARTY'S CALCULATIONS THAT I
COULD ONLY WIN BY IMPORTING A
NEW CLASS OF VOTERS, WHICH THEY
ARE TRYING YOUR BEST TO DO.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND A
COLUMNIST AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
MARK, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE A LECTURE ON A
BIBLE FROM HILLARY CLINTON OR
ABRUPT ON MIKE BARBARA BOXER OR
THE REST, BUT DO YOU FEEL
EDIFIED BY THIS?
>> IT'S INTERESTING, I THINK
BEING RATHER SELECTIVE IN THIS
IN THE FOCAL FERVOR.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO THE LEFT, AND
THAT'S WHAT IMMIGRATION IS.
IT'S PUBLIC POLICY.
HILLARY AND OF THE REST OF THE
LEFT, AND I REGRET NOW AN ENTIRE
PHALANX OF FIRST LADIES HAS
DECIDED THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
SENTIMENTAL IS A STUB PUBLIC
POLICY.
THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT IS
SUPPOSEDLY ON ORANGE ALERT.
OVER HALF OF THE ILLEGAL ALIENS
PRESENT BROKE INTO A COUNTRY ON
ORANGE ALERT.
THAT MEANS THEY COME HERE SINCE
9-11.
THE SECURITY DEMANDS TO KNOW THE
CONSISTENCY OF THAT PUMPKIN PIE
IF THEY ARE FLYING HOME TO
THANKSGIVING FROM NEW YORK TO
CLEVELAND, BUT THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS ENTITLED TO WALK ACROSS
THE RIO GRANDE IF THEY HAPPEN TO
HAVE A LITTLE MUPPET INTEL WITH
THEM.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
IF I MAKE A DOMESTIC FLIGHT,
THEIR BORDERS ARE OPEN AND I MAY
BE THE HARSHEST PERSON HERE
SPEAKING TONIGHT BECAUSE I KNOW
AS A LEGAL IMMIGRANT HOW
HEARTLESS AND RUTHLESS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION POLICY, AND THESE
DEMOCRATS, LAURA BUSH NEVER HAS
A WORD TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF YOU SHOWED UP TO THE AIRPORT
WITHOUT A DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
SAID IT, I HAVE A MORAL RIGHT TO
GET ON THIS PLANE INTO A RACIST
FOR NOT LETTING ME ON.
WHAT THAT WORK?
>> WE ARE BIFURCATING INTO A
SOCIETY WHERE THE LAW-ABIDING
ARE SUBJECT TO EVERMORE WHILE
THE LAWLESS HAVE SOMEHOW
VENERATED AND FETISH US.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU ACTUALLY
ARE FOREIGN BOARD       BORN.
AND I WAS CROSSING DERBY LINE,
AND RATHER THEY THREATEN TO CALL
EYES AND HAVE MY DAUGHTER
DEPORTED.
THEN SHE'D BE IN CANADA AND HE
WOULD BE STUCK HERE IN AMERICA,
AND I SAID I WOULD BE MUCH OF A
FATHER IF I DID THAT BECAUSE I
WILL TELL YOU 10 MINUTES AFTER
YOU DEPORT HER, I WILL BRING HER
BACK TO WHATEVER COUNTRY YOU
DEPORT HER TOO.
BECAUSE OF THE PRICE AND BEING
IN AMERICA IS THAT I HAVE TO BE
SEPARATED FROM MY CHILDREN, THEN
I PASSED.
AND I'M SURPRISED, FRANKLY, AND
ALL OF THESE HARDWORKING PEOPLE
ARE BEING SNATCHED FROM THE
BOSOMS OF THEIR MOTHERS.
IT'S SOULFUL AND HEARTBREAKING,
WHY DON'T WE JUST SAY AT THE
BORDER, YOU CAN COME IN BUT IF
YOU DO YOUR CHILDREN WILL BE
TAKEN FROM YOU.
THEN PEOPLE WILL SAY I DON'T
WANT TO BE SEPARATED FOR MY
CHILDREN, CAN I GO BACK ACROSS
THE RIO GRANDE TO THE SOUTHERN
SHORE.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT BETWEEN THE